un nuevo acuerdo para poner fin a la
crisis en sudán
el nuevo pacto alcanzado entre civiles y
la junta militar estipula el retorno del
primer ministro abdalá hand dog a su
cargo cuando se había mantenido en
arresto domiciliario desde que fue
derrocado el 25 de octubre las cifras de
los otros que hemos vivido una crisis
durante mucho tiempo gracias a dios hoy
estamos orgullosos de que con la firma
de este decreto político podamos sentar
una base real para nuestro periodo de
transición como lo imaginamos y como el
pueblo de sudán no quería al comienzo de
la transición el pacto contempla además
la formación de un gobierno de
tecnócratas durante el periodo de
transición la liberación de todos los
presos políticos y estipula que la
declaración constitucional de 2019
alcanzada tras la salida de omar al
bachir será la base para el cambio
político es el steve at
este acuerdo ayuda a liberar la asfixia
esperamos la asfixia interna externa y a
volver a la senda de la transición para
lograr una democracia duradera en
nuestro país
sin embargo lo pactado no alivió las
pensiones en las calles miles de
personas marcharon hacia el palacio
presidencial tras el anuncio del acuerdo
acusando al primer ministro de haber
vendido la revolución las
manifestaciones fueron dispersadas con
gases lacrimógenos
la coalición civil que había compartido
el poder con los militares antes del
golpe dijo que no reconoce el acuerdo y
la asociación de profesionales sudaneses
también se opuso el acuerdo traicionero
firmado hoy entre hanbok y al burham es
totalmente [__] y sólo concierne a
sus partidos los civiles se rechazan la
presencia de los militares en la
política sudanesa y exigen rendición de
cuentas ante la justicia para los
responsables de la toma militar se
estima que cerca de 40 personas murieron
en medio de la represión de las
protestas ciudadanas desde el 25 de
octubre